hey I want to talk about a new movie
based on his voice is warm and husky
like dark melted chocolate fudge caramel
or something seriously the new movie
Fifty Shades of Grey is based on an
insanely popular book franchise that
started life is a piece of erotic
Twilight fan fiction the author
envisioned hunky vampires and naughty
bondage scenarios and her work became so
popular that she went back and altered
names so she could sell her stories
without getting sued I asked you what
you thought of Fifty Shades and none of
you would admit to having read it come
on fess up I won't judge honest fanfic
is actually a vitally important part of
geek culture and its really having a
moment now Amazon's Kindle worlds is
officially publishing licensed fanfic
based on everything from Vampire Diaries
to Vonnegut an epic piece of one
direction fanfic was just option for a
book and a possible movie it's easy to
dismiss fanfic as the work of obsessives
eager to imagine popular characters in
sexy situations but the key component is
fans passionately engaging with the work
and digging more deeply into fictional
worlds than their creators ever did one
of the best sci-fi novels i read
recently john scalzi redshirts was a
tongue-in-cheek piece of Star Trek fan
Fang heck James Joyce's Ulysses was a
homer fanfic it shouldn't surprise us
that these works are making it to the
big screen because these days
Hollywood's all about cranking out these
loving Oh mashas that play like they're
100 million dollar pieces of fanfic JJ
Abrams is essentially making Star Trek
fanfic revisiting and reimagining
classic scenarios from the original
films super 8 was Abram spielberg fanfic
mixing elements of ET and Close
Encounters and what could possibly be
more fanfic even dreaming up an even
more badass lightsaber with a cross
guard
pacific rim is like the ultimate kaiju
fanfic come to think of it so is the
latest godzilla jason segel made a
muppet fanfic Chris Rock made a Woody
Allen fan fan and Woody Allen's
top-grossing film ever was a mary-sue
story about a culture guy like Woody
Allen who gets to hang out with
Hemingway and dictate the plot of
exterminating angel to Boone well
franchise reboots like Fast Five play
like fanfic ODEs to earlier installments
the expendables is Stallone doing
Stallone fanfic wolf of Wall Street is
like the ultimate Scorsese fanfic now
you can grumble about the lack of
originality but let's see I like most of
these movies I don't think this is
necessarily a bad thing what do you
think is Hollywood spending too much
time paying tribute to pass creations
let me know in the comments i also
invite you to write angry nerd fanfic
not the dirty guy right about how when
i'm not a mild-mannered web ranter i'm
off fighting crime with my mute
ridiculing power I need a superhero name
look the Tugela sure no that sounds like
dirty fan I don't really want to see or
read Fifty Shades of Grey but I'm glad
it's creating more space for fanfic in
the public imagination it also may help
me sell my completely original story
about the sensual interstellar smuggler
and so slow and his burning passion for
his hair suit lady copilot sue baka what
fanfic storyline would you like to see
turned into a movie let me know in the
comments as long as it's PG rated I
don't want to hear about Kirk getting
down with Spock click on my other videos
to the right and subscribe to the white
channel hey maybe I'll write a fanfic
about how these tiny versions of me are
my trusty sidekicks
you